all right and we are both live the last
word with Noah kognito and ebon tecee
branches what is going on sir uh you
know it's another week um
few more changes we got some updates
coming - destiny - we've got some future
games to look forward to we've got some
changes in some eras just lots of stuff
to talk about for week it's a it's been
a pretty good week has your day going so
far I know it's early but your days on
the on the tail end so you the vampire
life your vampire life man just happy
the weekend is actually here for me
getting excited about all the news
droppin big tois actually like the 12
I'm excited to get into that um anthem
division you mean like it's a good time
for gaming even uh Mortal Kombat drops
some stuff yeah that's all that's here
fatalities are hard to get tired oh I'm
still just kidding yeah how amazing is
that franchise just to keep on going man
so yeah it's just it's been really cool
a lot of stuff going on and uh I've
actually been playing a lot of destiny
got some in uh finally getting my Forge
grind really doing those bounties and
I've been kind of staying with the first
one and just just getting stuff done and
mess around with that whole gameplay
loop and understanding it you know I'm
saying so doing that night turner group
a ton chorus but actually a lot of
competitive - men a lot of competitive -
so we we get into dates in certain parts
of it swap Allah talked about that as
well - yeah it's it's been a pretty
crazy week I did want to shout out
I got a shout out Guardian radio they
had that last episode literally
yesterday I mean for me and I said it's
a mark before as well shout out to those
guys the good work they put into
literally Craig Mark byph k-dubb Bell
bunny and even the guys before that they
didn't list - Mesa Sean as well I mean
he does so much so all that stuff going
they wrapped up their last episode and
it's like the end of the era I mean
those guys have been going for nearly
six years which is just insane mmm I
mean they were doing it before the game
even started and they're kind of going
out with destinies in a really good spot
actually
they just they have other things but it
was it was just a little you know kind
of somber just to listen to everything
they were saying but I mean for mark and
all the stuff that he does if you guys
ever have wanted to listen to just some
some of the nicest guys out there check
out a couple of their recent ones at
least give them a nice view on there see
if we can bump up their view count on
that last finale episode just a bunch of
nice guys and they they started this
community as one of the earliest
podcasts out there and there's a lot of
ones that have spawned up our is destiny
community I mean you've got so many
crews already oh there's so many over
time that have come from that and it was
just I don't know it was it was kind of
weird to listen to that last one yeah
very strange well said well said I mean
yeah I mean those guys are pioneers and
we've had mark on the show you know
tremendous got tremendous community I
got a chance to meet both k-dub and um
Mesa Sean at the destiny come for us
Guardian con and um great guys again
they've been doing it so long and it's
always sad to see something go you know
Sam at the same time it's just like you
know you have to respect it's like damn
like you get selfish as a listener you
know saying so being a listener of a
podcast you always get selfish but you
know salute to those guys Bennett though
those guys were the first over the
Pioneers older guys to really put this
thing on the map and what is it six
years waiting like six oh that's that's
a long time so definitely salute to
longevity and hopefully man like I said
you know those guys are happy and doing
what they want to do man so definitely
salute yeah so I mean mark I know is
gonna go on to do other stuff
Mesa still got his channel qdubs doing I
mean family life is definitely a thing
it's just like as things go on there I
mean they can just you know you know
count their blessings that they got to
do it that long cuz honestly things like
this don't last forever is like we're
lucky to be still doing this after a
year because you know so you never know
other things can change and there may be
a time where like our time of this
podcast will maybe have to change if
life happens but that'll happen down the
road but we will still try and get to
this as frequent as we can because we
still enjoy talking about games
especially these that you guys
absolutely though we get the last word
on these
[Laughter]
so yeah I mean first things first we had
the twelve and destiny dropped yesterday
not waiting for like three weeks so we
actually got some good info in there
so Niobe Labs has been open for week
people have been doing the Bertuzzi
afford a couple things have been
dropping a few more yo tons are getting
out there which feels busted but
hilarious I don't have it yet but I mean
the videos I've seen it just looks kind
of stupidly broken fun so that's
definitely one of those to grind for the
boss of the burgers here for just a tank
and if you got whispered it's over just
follow them literally just yeah jump up
in the top corner where you spawn in and
it's you know knock it out honestly the
latest forges are the easier ones
because is an omni like chunking them up
they're really not too bad
Gil Fannin Ford's that second one still
artist really that yeah that teleporting
servitors like the hardest one the guy
making what is it the big not Centurion
the big colossus guy he's not easy per
se but yeah if you take sleeper into
Izanagi is it not me sorry I get those
confused cuz is it not use the sniper
yes if you take sleeper in there and you
got a couple people that have sleeper
yeah before he moves I mean he goes so
fast like that Hydra does not have as
much health the sleeper thunderlord with
well of radiance like couple people
stalling there I mean speaking my
language
yeah I was like you play some of those
guys pretty quick and it's just the
servitor feels like it just has so much
health and it just boots you around
everywhere and teleports and everything
so yeah it's rough and even yesterday
like some of the grind is real because I
love my go figure anybody who's watching
my videos yes my go figure is my laser
beam going we gotta get your you gotta
get your blast furnace you gotta get
your blast furnace I was like my roles
have sucks really Oh they've been awful
I'll get stuff like you might get
something like oh you might have a
moment with like air assault or drag
shot it's all bs roles there I hate wait
and then and then I hear people like
just you know I'll be playing in twitch
talking about this one somebody or
somebody comments on a video like oh I
got the feeding frenzy range master work
rampage I'm like screw you
I mean I have might go figure that is
basically that everybody
just like all the blast furnaces better
it's like I'm gonna get like 100 these
things before I do it so I mean the
fastest place is that place on Mars I
put a video up about yesterday so yeah
like you guys could you know could have
used that one a little while ago but
that's I mean it's a pretty fast grind
and it's so funny like that's actually
one of the videos where I've probably
had more comments of people saying where
they prefer to grind it out but not that
many down votes like oh this is terrible
it's just like more people saying hey I
go here apparently everybody likes their
own lost sector on the Dreaming City it
literally heard all three I've heard
chamber of Starlite if aliens rest and
and the way of joining wishes I've
literally heard all three mentioned and
because the idea is like some will say
the Bay of drowning wishes cuz I'm like
well you have to if you want to do the
boss twice you still have to kill all
the ads and a second you can run to the
end some people just like take sleep or
the one in Mars that one's cool the
affiliates are rest that one's actually
not bad because you can run through
shoot the boss and then just you know
run back out and come back and then
Chamber of Starlights not bad either so
it just kind of depends on your
preference it's nice that there's
variety out there it's just the one that
works for me so you know some people
like hey go ahead and take graviton
lance in there and do this that in the
other and it was like well I try not to
assume anybody has an exotic again but
the video is out there for for the newer
players or the casuals are the ones
don't have all the stuff so yeah you
probably do you even have grabbed on
lands him oh I had to get it from sir
you know some of us not so fortunate
with RNG I still have have no warlock
forsaken exotic armor still you and you
and Mesa shunkan can all that guy just
sounds depressed every time it was
nothing up on Twitter and he's like he's
like looking at the exotic engrams like
ah do I even want to pick this thing
he's like yep third is still trash
alright he just like he cannot get new
armor to save his little at this point I
should do like a docu-series de 242
continues as we sit out here in the
fields of the creaming city and out and
as I waste away waiting I see another
exotic engrams dropping oh no oh no
again it is a year one exotic of trash
if you move on doing eggs drop its just
let yeah
Payne bro but I'll be the only the only
thing that saves me that the reason why
I don't complain is because coming from
console to PC I am living proof that
thunderlord drops as an exotic oh yeah
you got it early that and Luna faction
boots because that's one of my real
world yeah yeah do what you need to get
done I can hold my own solo you know and
that's what saving me if I didn't have
those two I would be in trouble so
that's the only reason why I'm calming
down because I got my sense she was my
other third essential which I still
haven't got which I'm hoping when you
put that serve video up later today is
um it was it without I need my NASA Rex
and I mean that's a big part of my fully
in that helm yeah but you know what's
funny real quick before we get into it
um I got a new build now and I don't
even know if I might go back to Nazareth
when we learn about certain other
exotics getting nerfed um I've been
really sleeping on transverses steps
I got a shout those out in creepy right
transverses man cuz it you know what it
is especially you hand cannon users if
you guys shout the Forte the cherry I
know he got a Lunas how um the thing
about it is no matter Hank end up the
main thing is really no you just run a
couple of seconds and your guns reloaded
like that is such a huge deal like you
have no it is saved me so it's like this
passive ability that you really under
eight and it's been so much fun so I've
been out here and and we're gonna talk
about malfeasance - oh man now I don't
know what it is on PC I don't know
what's going on but man I put up a seven
point eight yesterday man man I got a
new I don't even call a boss full name I
call it the mouse easy that's the
nickname mouth fees they don't want it
with the mouse easy right there that
shows Mercer step so that's what I got
yeah I mean for me my last week I didn't
even spend that much time in the forge
is like I'm kind of back on the grind
for blast furnace but last week for me
was shattered throne
you got to see a little bit of that cuz
if what they sweated through laughs I
felt I felt they should've gave you that
I hate them I know those of you guys
that didn't catch it live or haven't
just followed my Twitter's Twitter swell
I'm feel like I'm twenty thousand years
old so shattered Thrones still pain in
the butt but I was working on the solo
flawless run and I was going through
practicing went through died at one
point so it's like okay doing a practice
run jump back in the second one and had
just like a stupid death in the first
section and I was like alright well and
it looked like when I came back in like
the Check Point started not at where you
initially spawned you have to like go
through the first door and there's no
ads but it was like well crap does that
sound like does that count as a full run
and I don't know so I went with my
brother and he hadn't run it on whatever
character was on yet and we started out
and I literally just had him load up
shattered throne like the first initial
door like widow just load in spawn and
then I left so I could try and reset my
checkpoint Franz then I left completely
left went in on my own separately and
then I would like spawned in after the
door and it's like well I don't know if
it counts but at this point I got to
finish it and find out so I went through
pulled a flawless run completely all the
way through finished akaru and
everything which was just like
nail-biting the whole time the ogre is a
pain in the butt and then got pseudo
akaru
like was actually getting uh like
everything was just kind of coming
together burn her down and I saw the
first trial pop and I was like oh I got
the I got the finish it flawless I was
waiting for the second one to come up
and it did not show and I was like oh so
somehow like having my brother in there
like it instanced me with him and even
just because it was the first instance
or whatever cuz I was paired with him it
was not solo flawless it was just
flawless so couple weeks from now I'll
have to put it back through its paces
and get it going again because then I
tried later and I had a good run going
and then like the ogre somehow I've like
exploded a wizard without even knowing
it and just it was just my mojo it was
shot kind of after a point itself it's
like some of you guys were watching live
but it was yeah I still love that place
that man
that was like kind of a heartbreak when
things yeah we were watching we would
cheer you on me forte and Indy bro we
know yeah Oh at least I killer it was
one only one point it got a little dicey
for young bucks oh man I had a couple
like just pucker moment sores like had a
couple of those but yeah hold out I had
machine-gun reserves
I had thunderlord busting out the damage
I like melted and I've noticed something
I don't know why somebody said it in my
twitch chat - sometimes thunderlord cast
like eight lightning bolts at the same
time yes it does like yeah I've seen
it's like and it's all the sudden it's
like you'll do your normal like burn
through stuff and then it's none of a
sudden like and that's one of those
times when I ran on the ogre that one I
was just going along all of a sudden his
health was like down a third like
instantly I didn't I saw it do it to
somebody else - at one point minutes
like okay that's a cool like proc when
it happens but it was still kind of
insane yes add the fourth day he said
that floating warlock jump almost did it
did you oh yeah there's the flute got me
once - it did get me pretty early on
when I was doing my first practice run
so I was just like I was in like the it
was in the descent not the first section
with the captain outside but I would
call like the Cathedral looking area
before the catwalk and just in there I
was going upstairs to get a mo and I
just didn't like one jump on my second
one or spacebar I didn't take it it was
just like any other character I probably
could have recovered something like that
warlocks just nope going down all right
and I was just like and it was just one
of those like facepalm moment I was like
well this is now a practice run yeah
yeah and that's kind of just like that
was the dungeons are awesome I just hope
we get some more of those down the road
because I really love them yeah now you
did you take my salute to you and that
that sort of solo runs man you are
killing it with getting it down to a
science do being efficient great to
watch man thanks well trust me you'll
still have to scold me in PvP down the
road so oh yeah I'm school mouths easy
continue
yeah all that all that being said that's
mostly would be we've been doing we'll
get to some of the news that's dropped
about other games toward the end so you
guys are looking for stuff about
division and anthem we will be talking
about both of those today but those will
be towards the end once we wrap with the
destiny stuff but we're gonna start here
in the world of this week at Bungie so
dropped yesterday and we got a nice
little bit of news from Luke Smith so to
talk about the future of the game basic
pieces they said there's a seer thanks
to the people at Activision who helped
bring destiny together and that's a big
thing it's like I just need like
probably would not have happened without
Activision because I mean 500 million
dollars doesn't just fall in people's
hands high Moon Studios for the
collaboration of forsaken Vicarious
Visions who've helped with like black
armory and PC port which can't let the
police PC ports amazing but that's and
they said they're gonna finish up with
their swan song for season of the
redacted and stuff but basically what
that means is those other studios
they're still Activision studios so
you've got serious visions who helped
you know moon studios who helped the
best need to and now they truly are on
their own Islands yeah those other
Studios so that's like that's a work
force that's a base of people that
they've been using that they don't have
now so they said in the short term
they're gonna continue building the
content black armory and they've learned
some things from that so they're trying
to you know roll at the next pieces of
the annual pass they said you know they
are committed to destiny they you know
if the futures in their hands the vast
majority of the team is hard at work
envisioning future experiences enemies
ways to play The Guardian you've been
building since 2014 so and then finally
just somebody had kind of an interesting
question here so is it it it was a busy
fall it's gonna be a busy year III I'm
sure is gonna be insane and they don't
even say that but they said when I look
ahead and think about destiny and where
it could go I see a bright future with
roots in a memorable past which is a
very interesting line depending on what
they want to do with say maybe old
content I don't know not everything has
been lost in the dark corners of time
mm-hm that last a little bit I mean Luke
Smith definitely doesn't he doesn't jump
out much right it's kind of a big deal
so has to have him post something and
this is definitely pretty cool mm-hmm
absolutely what do you what do you read
in all that
and your thoughts on the future I think
it's it's it this is more of a comfort
the base you don't let everyone know hey
man you know we obviously had a gonna
call it tumultuous week but you know
it's been an eventful week for their
future so I guess they want to assure
people you know with the status of the
annual pass which is kind of setting up
letting know that they're gonna continue
but what they promise that was that that
second paragraph you know and long term
when I see that sentence you know we
created universe we hold his future
Italian our hands the vast majority team
is hard at work provisioning the future
experiences and enemies and way to play
the garden you've been building to 2014
so again assurance it's you know what I
get from it
hey we made a big move but like be clear
we're kind of confident in what we're
doing like because I noticed I don't
wanna say there's a cloud but even I had
some concerns obviously you know because
we always talk about you know big bad
evil activision right and but at the
same time you know last you know last
word we talked about how like you know
there's a lot of things that activision
we're doing that you know people may
take for granted and whether it be you
know the marketing we saw and so forth
the PC port who let's be honest it's
fantastic right that is a great great
port so um you know it's one of those
things where I see like this is more of
okay we went through something you know
we're do a breakup but everything's
gonna be okay uh you know continue to
the annual pass and I agree I think III
we're gonna learn a lot you know because
that's gonna definitely set up the big
content you know quote-unquote comet
that's their own and it is also gonna be
big from the standpoint of obviously no
Vicarious Visions
no hi moon at that point I'm assuming
that should be the cutoff according to a
whole or which we haven't showed our
honorable podcast who broke everything
down legally so from a contractual
obligation hi moon free carriers should
see it through all the way to annual
pass and I'm assuming at that point
there'll be a cut-off at that point
we'll know the state of PlayStation
exclusives whether or not that continues
yeah right whether or not Sony tries
will pay and say hey I want to keep this
going even though the active is your
deal is
coke dissolved you know does Microsoft
step in you know it's gonna be very
interesting we'll learn a lot and it's
exciting I'm definitely excited to see
how they handle it and we know as we'll
talk about later that there's a
competition on the way so you know it's
good it's good stuff is good stuff I'm
excited to see what they do man they got
they got their IP back at the end of the
day that is rare I've never seen in I'm
you know I'm not the youngest gamer in
the room in my history I've never really
seen situations like that so kudos to
their lawyers been able to secure such a
deal from leaving mark self to go into
the to Activision and still having the
you know the mindset of if things don't
work out we hold on to the IP yeah I
mean it's just nice to see them do that
as always I mean thing I think hitman
Kenna did a similar thing recently with
uh I forget who makes that damn game IO
or something like that I don't even know
but yeah it's just nice to see them hold
it but as you said the earnest is on
them too you know at this point put up
or shut up
cuz I'm actually the excuses are no
longer with anybody else it's totally on
them and but I mean you read this line
here is like when I look at and think
about destiny and where it could go I
see a bright future with roots and a
memorable past not everything has been
lost in the dark corners of times it
looks like is there anything related to
I mean it's like it would be hilarious
if they just took d1 and d2 and smash
them together
what if they brought back like just the
old content and so I was like I don't
know you just think about like what has
been lost and stuff it would be I don't
know it's like they slowly devil with
like exotics and stuff but you know
different areas and things but yeah I'm
look but much rather see more future
than just slapping on old content Rocha
it's like we got I don't know just it's
the the world is their oyster at this
point however they choose to he'll go
forward will be very very interesting
absolutely man this actually gets me I'm
gonna be at e3 this year actually gives
me very excited because um
we'll get it baby get hopefully get a
sneak peek of what's going on and then
obviously we know they're gonna be at
Guardian con which me and you will be
there so we will get even more
information on assume yeah
because at that part we should have
already an announcement and more
hopefully
do you think I mean my guess III is
gonna be the big one I mean if they're
something they want to throw out and
have a little bit of fun with like I
mean gambit was a new yeah on me but is
like is there gonna be a whole new mode
that's that's hard for them to come up
with what they I mean I still think they
will be there it's too big and I think
they've got a the independence now from
Activision as well to be like well yeah
we're gonna go like I think they get to
make those choices now if where they
want to go but it's also again you think
about like you know even just the you
know content creators and influencers of
stuff that Activision pays for it's like
Activision pays that build not Bungie
pays the bill for them to go up to
Seattle or go to an e3 so it's like a
lot of those costs still are gonna be
one of those things they've got to
figure out where budgets go what they
can afford so there's there's definitely
a lot of things to evaluate and we'll
see what it takes for them to do it on
their own
so absolutely yeah so that I mean that's
kind of the future so we'll see what
things hold but you know I'm as always
cautiously optimistic because you know
it's basically an uncharted territory at
this point you know yeah but they do we
know on the 29th couple weeks we're
gonna be getting not even a couple weeks
like 11 days mm-hmm
we're gonna be getting our updates to
the super-abilities in the damn ago we
talked about all that stuff last week so
if you guys missed that one tune in last
week look on the Bungie blog and you
check all that stuff out they also want
to talk about the sandbox yeah
which is like a it's like our biannual
sandbox update once every six months
listen to the sarcasm in his voice yeah
sandbox is covered right oh I'm excited
you gotta jump this is awful yeah let me
just kind of say in here so designer
Victor Anderson has a rundown of our
goals and the changes being made to
reach them so I'm gonna hit the high
points I'm gonna let you hit the details
so main things they want to buff
underutilized weapon archetypes which
and that hopefully obvious adjust
hot-button weapons in PvP including
Telesto which we all know is they may be
waves definitely thing on ps4 that I've
heard
but I know Android PvP adjustments that
will negatively affect PvE efficacy and
that's important that they keep making
that distinction between those two they
need to keep those separate because I
mean PDE can't suffer just because PDP
has to somehow balance you can't have
like all this guns trash now because we
had the balance of a PvP
I'm sure that can still keep those
separate so it's Lulu first weapon
archetypes all you yeah man so it looks
like they hit an auto rifles first or
damage increased for rapid fire adaptive
and high impact families we find that
auto rifles are a little unforgiving for
the ranges they asked you to occupy in a
world with special weapons shotguns and
as a result you've increased the damage
to offset the higher risk then we have
scout rifles damage increased for
lightweight and rapid-fire families as
well as an increase to all scout rifles
in PvE Oh scout rifles are always going
to be on the lower end of them which due
to the safety that their range affords
you but the difference currently between
them and other primary weapons is too
drastic as a result we're reducing the
size of the gap and then we have sniper
rifles increase the damage on the
rapid-fire archetype to be able to kill
in two body shots so the two tap was
back although snipers are still finding
success we believe that allowing you to
clean up a kill easier with a sniper
rifle will allow the Stamper to have the
success at more ranges and in more
situations and they go off into some
exotics which are very important um
legend of a curious I was surprised by
this one I'm good to see increase the
damage and bumped out the range slightly
as the time moves on things tend to
trend upward in terms of power and then
a post forsaken world accurate simply
doesn't have the output to match other
heavy weapon exotics here we go
we got frame frame the whole page make
sure you got full reading we know it
listed ladies general we knew this was
coming this was a this is a multiple
offender this guy right here he's been
running rampant for a while so Telesto
formerly the best though pvp damage
brought down
to match a standard fusion rifle charge
rate optics was also increased to match
fusion rifles with long range scopes
Telesto has become fairly notorious in
the crucible for its effectiveness even
in some cases getting accidental multi
kills due to how damaging explosions
were to combat these we reduce its PvP
damage to match its charge rate this
brought up an issue which doing so was
significantly hurting the usability of
the weapon so the optics were buffed in
return in general you should still find
it ineffective weapon it just won't be
quite as generous as it was before what
do you think about the formal former
best though I got to talk about this one
quick I haven't done much competitive
I've definitely heard nothing but stuff
about I mean it doesn't a range drop-off
the fact that the little particles can
go pretty much across map and if they
catch you they catch you and it's just
like it's it's a monster I mean it's an
exotic but it's it's a little broken to
a plane so then it needed it we knew it
was coming and while I haven't heard
like I haven't seen it personally as
much that's all I hear about for
competitiveness later you can't not go
in there with that thing if you want to
try and be in the mix so yeah yeah I
think that's the point of their main
focus is like they want it like you
think about scout rifles and autos and
it's like they just don't quite hold up
so they need a little they need some
boost like if the whole world uses one
gun there's something wrong and there's
a point where you can't forever buff to
catch things up like there's a point
where something's that far out of whack
yeah you're gonna tweak it back down
just a great man I agree and then uh
Trace rifles we've got increased the
minimum amount of ammo that you can
receive from special ammo boxes that's
actually a big deal Trace rifles had a
pretty rough time keeping em reserves in
the crucible as it doesn't have enough
how doesn't have access to scavenger
perks you should have more success using
it in often the crucible now and this
changes will also affect PvE bricks and
then reduce the strength of waves
whether in PvP after the ammo changes
noted above wave splitter had its one
weakness removed so we opted to bring it
in line with the other trade rifles
before the patch hit the public yeah I
mean I've heard I haven't honestly
touched wave splitter but I've heard
it's pretty lethal out there on pure
but yeah it's like it's so weird that
they don't have trace rifles tied to
some type of perks I mean I thought they
were affected by auto rifles to a point
so sounds weird but it's like they just
they're kind of they're a weapon type
and they don't have a perk rolled into
yeah you dunce but you don't have like
trace fries it's not there you can't
build for it it's just to the point if
it's weird so I mean you could do oh no
it just it feels like it should have
happened a while ago or at least I don't
know how it just I think I overlooked or
they thought it would be addressed with
something else so it's just kind of
weird
yeah manless I mean I definitely think
it is it was kind of weird traits but I
think you just come down to utilization
and I think maybe you just forgot
obviously because it's not getting
utilized as much you know but it is a
weird a mission kind of thing so it they
conclude the paragraph by saying weapon
tunings is an ongoing process we'll be
sure to talk to you more about it in the
future some topics we're looking at for
future potential adjustments include
trace travel trace rifle damage in PvE
that's a big one um cold heart looking
at you some gun damage adjustments
that's a big one um shotgun adjustments
and taking a holistic look at the heavy
slot options and how much of an option
it has on the loadout choices for PvE
content we're always looking at what's
currently in use and what isn't in use
as having more choices always better
than being locked into a narrow brown so
overall you know what do you feel about
the weapon archetype effected and the
direction is kind of handing with those
exotics I mean you see stuff like trace
rifles like I don't see those use that
often you can do it for fun I mean you
can even use something like what is the
solar one of course I blink when I try
and say that I am prometheus we did yeah
you could use Prometheus and it's like
if you're gonna melt some ads and stuff
for a little while maybe it's a solar
burn you can have some fun you get that
animal coming back if you got the
catalyst is actually pretty decent but
again when you use that exotic as they
kind of get to that point you take away
the heavy exotics and those are so
powerful right now I mean thunderlord if
not thunderlord basically all machine
guns if you have it yeah but those are
insanely powerful
whispers always there leapers definitely
your baby
people's just because that one shot is
so massive let me but again like an
exotic heavy probably should outweigh
something like you know special or a
primary but again if I'm gonna use it
exotic it needs to make a difference
like right I got a I got an ornament
from MIT a multi-tool and about laughs
because it's like who's gonna pull MIT a
multi-tool out and use that exotic and
take away your ability to use
thunderlord
and on top of it being a scout so I mean
like suros regime while you can have
some fun in a couple places it's alright
but yeah there's just a lot of stuff
that feel there's always gonna be a meta
there's no question about that and it's
gonna shift and change but they are so
slow that we feel like we get entrenched
into these meadows and for so long I
mean they mention submachine gun
adjustments I'm like I honestly don't
know where to put that I know some
people use submachine guns or sidearms
and PvP for that kind of like cleanup
thing I can't imagine anybody using that
stuff in PvE those don't even have a
place they don't have a place yeah yeah
it's like fusions are gonna have a
little more power from that little mid
to longer range if you want that special
shot and snipers are kind of still a
weird spot outside of whisper just is
ope and you're almost nigh / still feels
odd hmm but yeah submachine guns and
sidearms I'm like the I mean you have a
breakneck you can go in for that I've
got my go figure
you've got shotgun it's like where do
those fit in things that need to
establish themselves and have a place
yeah gaming for taste and cold heart is
in the forges is great yeah it's like
certain ones have a spot but yeah it's
definitely a lot of things don't right
now well what I'm hoping is that some of
those exotics that you mentioned you
know as far as like suros we talked
about mighta you know and then sniper
I've got to remember that when they buff
these weapon archetypes that you have to
understand that the exotics in that will
also get affected so we hopefully should
see in orders like the soros hopefully
be a little bit more better you know
with this damage increase again we don't
know how big the damage increase is yet
i mean but then you have scouts like
matter i'm assuming not so much maybe I
mean they did say they're gonna unbox it
in PvE
we ever see but again I'm with you I'm
not gonna take my dough
but up it's gonna it's gonna be
interesting and I'm saying some of those
youtl on underutilized archetypes to see
how that um goes in man O'Neill man -
what's up brother how you doing man oh
boy distracting that's going on so um
yeah you see that
I like that actor it's got that bomb I
am a big-time Telesto offender so listen
it this was coming it's very forgiving
you can shoot down a block there's no
damage fall-off you can still get
craziness off multi kills off whole
bunch of foolishness going on that I was
like I felt guilty the stuff I was doing
with Telesto I was just like yeah they
say right so why not and literally it
was my only counter to the lunar howl
users because luna house running all
over the crucible in competitive and at
least if I didn't win we would trade so
it's gonna be interesting because they
claim at the weapons still gonna be
effective we shall see trace rifles daph
filly Neil um I have a news trace rifle
since like damn vanilla when Cole Hall
was a thing in against like Callas
remember mm-hmm like I can't remember
and you know Prometheus I love the look
but you know they're gonna have to do
something about it man job the Crisco
release that he had to use two less
though the other day against the sweats
and quickly I felt you feel dirty you do
but you got to do it you know what's up
dramatic and it's just you can't it's if
you are wanting to just play your own
style it's fine play with whatever guns
you want and sometimes people like you
know what I just want to go in there
with some funky stuff mix it up for a
little bit see how it goes and just mess
with some weapon types but if you really
want to go if you want to try and be at
the top of the game you need to use the
top of the meta and that's just how that
goes it right now there's one gun that
does that in PvP and hardly other things
compare heavies only so often from
bricks which they have pulled back from
some but still feels like it just pops
up a little quick but I mean that
Telesto if you can get that ammo go and
you can get that like cross map shot tag
those people will get the explosions
like it's just really ultra powerful and
it's tough yeah
so yeah I mean I'm happy to see it you
know obviously I didn't think they were
gonna do this and they did this you know
we have this in conjunction with the
older subclass or boss so it's gonna be
a nice little I love stuff like I just
need more frequency maybe quarterly
right like let's let's get these go I
love stuff like this so it's good to see
that this is happiness as a quite a
surprise but like you said before I
don't want to wait six months after this
for the next you know I mean it feels
like I mean when was the last one when
was the last real sandbox update I don't
even remember launch it forsaken
probably probably it's what it feels
like I mean we're guessing and not
looking back I'm sure that's kind of the
one because that's probably about the
time Celeste has been out there in
competitive doing its thing so yeah it's
like they need a quicker frequency on
this stuff I know they want to get all
the data and analyze it and do their
testing and I try not to break it and I
think a lot of us sometimes honestly
would be ok if things are a little
broken if they're willing to say be like
ok how quick can we change things right
I mean fortnight's like kind of a weird
thing but it is always in a beta phase
they get through some consult weeks
where they can you know not be early
access packet they can still do those
changes all the time because they have
the seasons and everything and they need
to find a way to do that for this to
really continue to adapt because if
you'll just get tired of playing PvP or
this one meta sucks and it doesn't
change for six months you're like well
kiss that part of the game goodbye maybe
I'll try and they can't really afford
that now they can't really afford Oh a
lot of chunks of people not would think
that would decapitation is coming well
god the Cobra agrees that I love did you
all
I don't eat you Joe to news I finally
enjoy the way whatever the gun that I
don't like
Jochen that thing is you know I don't
want complaint just yet but it feel easy
if I don't know if it feel like a boob
tube something gonna new - I don't know
man I don't know it just feel people
were hitting me which start I was like
this thing seemed like it's gonna be a
problem again I'm trying to keep back my
salt levels there
but it man man it felt young Neil Melton
say yup is Opie I don't want it I don't
want to go crazy yet but cuz I've only
experienced it in about two competitive
matches and maybe iron banner two days
ago have you fought you haven't made any
company been doing it I mean I've seen
videos of what that thing does just like
cross mapping and a little bit of
trouble do to set me up like what
they'll do is they'll control the
hallway and they'll peek out like hey so
yeah I'm gonna get boom the minute you
peek from distance I'm like damn this
thing is yeah yo - man yo - huh
who ever got that right now they got
some advantages so shout-out to the Mega
Man gun causing terror right now no and
again it's like they'll introduce stuff
some people having fun with izanagi's
like that one definitely is like I mean
you can use that thing for the big you
know one shot body shot if you can get
four bullets and if you can run around
and hold the special ammo but yeah
you're definitely sucking up all this
like fallouts videos like you're gonna
be a vacuum cleaner for the special ammo
nobody's getting anything if you're
running or none of that so okay so you
got you like you're scared you purchased
know that what is Sidda fusion isn't AAG
use the sniper rifle no it's not a big
sniper
yo turns fusion though yeah god sure you
right you right yeah yeah all these
changes so you get the Super's sandbox
more things come in weapon balancing a
lot of stuff coming on the twenty-ninth
with that last word so we're gonna get a
quest but we're gonna get a new feel for
the game all over again so we'll see how
all that stuff settles in I'm sure
people will see if there's a new meta
new things that work well hopefully
there's a little bit of variety which is
good yes sir uh so next piece this is
unity of life break this down so we've
got sandbox is the only it will not be
the only aspect of destiny to receiving
changes they spend some time collecting
player feedback on the black armor
experience how long is black armor been
out by the time this is gonna happen
about two months two months and this is
again where it's like some of you they
made the quick like couple quick changes
where they open the forge and then lower
the level of fur
one but some of these should have
happened sooner by the feedback that
I've seen pretty much everywhere I'm at
school so the first one ballistics logs
will no longer be removed at reset thank
you hahaha
seriously like that's one of those like
if you spend the time to do a weekly
bounding you have a currency to buy
those things and you know what like yeah
and if you have multiple characters then
you know maybe you don't have to grant
maybe you spend a lot of time on one
week and you can go through every frame
and every bounty on every character and
you're like okay cool
knock them all out next week you go
through you do the bounties but you
don't get to those other characters at
least you don't waste your time if you
do it and so I mean removing those was
just kind of an annoying they don't
remove many other things from a weekly
reset and they felt like doing that once
I still didn't quite understand it ya
know they will sack the limit for
ballistics logs to 5 per character so
you'll be able to hold 5 but you will
still only be able to do two powerful
frames per week so yeah limit goes but I
mean if you go through like say there's
like hey I just want to focus on the
pulse rifle this week I don't get
anything else and they did I got two
yeah it's like so I'm saving them up and
next week there's two cool or I just
start saving them up and then you don't
have to do those bounties as much so
it's a wait that if you put the time in
early you can save it for later so
that's kind of reasonable they will say
the weapon frames carried across the
reset will now refund into the following
so if you have a weapon frame in
progress if you have different levels
you won't completely lose them but you
have to start them over gold frames
which is your powerful frames will
refund into a ballistics log which is
fair if you don't finish it at least you
get it back silver frames which should
be the Augmented weapon ones if I'm
reading that correctly or just the
middle ones actually right those will
refund into three modulus reports now
those are worth six so I guess that's
half so it's in your benefit to finish
them but it's still at something any
instance of a radiant matrix will be
removed on weekly reset which honestly I
mean I don't know why they care but I
guess if you're removing the bounty you
probably have to remove the radiant
matrix because then it's just like a
weird step in there just be like instant
done I guess that kind of makes sense
just for progress through each step
players should stop experience the issue
where frames are missing from ADA's
inventory on a week to week basis
that's been really annoying so
somebody's coming back yeah so that
should be a good thing
players may still only purchase up to
two gold frames per week and again
that's per character yeah if you have
multiple characters you can go get all
three you just have to do it on other
characters so all the stuff seems
reasonable like the ballistics logs
coming back but removing them that was
just like an easy step yeah now there's
one major major major quality life thing
let's go not take out what's got what
stop having me go back to ADA just stop
it like don't make me do the pulse rifle
multi kills the radiance seeds just to
go back like if I pick up that frame and
I want to go grind a couple forges I can
literally finish it in there while I'm
grinding without having to go back again
it's just more loading and it's like
actually it's not as bad but on console
it hasn't just got to be worse I know it
is oh and yeah oh it's got to be
terrible yes like that step should it's
like why do I have to go back in there
just to be like one more step and I'm
gonna say it until it changes because
it's just a waste of time
hey don't get your because all you do
yet the radiant seeds and all she does
is just turn the quest that frame into
one you take to the forge and like as
soon as you pick up the radiant seeds
you should be able to go to a forge
because then some people if they just
want to grind the forges they pick up
the frame or call their multi kills in
there while there we're going to modulus
reports and you just make the grind a
little more reasonable and just less
loading back and forth in game time and
that's just that's the quality of life
thing that they drop all right as I
still not there I agree completely right
that should have been in this I agree
yeah so that one lacking drastically
aside the drop rate for the black armory
lore increased from 10% to 20% now
require successful ignition for a chance
to drop know some you guys may not know
what this is about the lore pages which
is how you guys actually get to know
what the hell's going on in black labs
and all that stuff but honestly that'll
be a topic here for a second but the way
people have been trying to grind these
out is the fact that they would equipped
like the lowest light level stuff
possible like cosmetic gear so you'd be
down to like 100 200 light level so when
you get match-made you're so low you
don't pair with anybody just low to
forge
I fail and they just do that over and
they just literally leave it running
like overnight to trail it from pages
because you can all you had to do is
finish a forge and you had a chance for
it to drop
and people were farming those I mean
most people were I think a lot of people
who were doing it were not complete
trash about it I have seen some afk
burrs but not a ton so they'd find like
a three-person team every nobody would
move Wow it'd be just you know they're
just not even touching their controller
just trying to get lower pages I'm like
if they're doing you have to try and get
the story now that's dust I'm sorry but
like the lore should be something that's
a little more easily accessible than a
random low grind of stuff to figure out
what's like that's the stuff we want to
know about because the story if you read
it is actually kind of cool dirt is good
too it's like that's my major beef with
armory I don't think the content is bad
I actually have fun doing the forges but
it's like it's just so just no we talked
about it when it launched it was just so
matter-of-fact like go to spy go to this
chick that's just randomly here
apparently in this tower that is always
the sister are waiting I'm getting to
that but then go to spider come back and
then it's just you know fetch fetch but
like I want to know about you like why
are you so mad at Guardians you know I
mean like it just was like yeah why are
you so pissed off exactly like I just
wish that's the only thing I missed from
the old motto at least there was some
attempt at the story build it in they
just rushed the introduction of this
character and from what I'm hearing what
you're saying with these long pieces I'm
hearing her backstory is great and it's
like it's really cool but now you're
putting it behind
Lauren G and lo percent chances and now
it's 20 percent like why why can't we
just get this information told to us
some other way if you're not gonna do
Mattox but you got to do it some way
better than R and G and hope that I
learn what's going on so I agree got a
problem with that yeah whether it's like
you know every forged completion so far
like you know eight is just like kind of
checks and be like oh well this is you
know kind of cool information about this
one let me tell you about this part of
like just a little
voiceover lines yeah it doesn't mean you
have to go back to her to hear about
enough stuff anyway just have a record a
few more of these things yes and just
have you learn about it more when you go
back to you know say you do some forages
you go back to orbit and be like you
know you've knocked out another five
forges here this is and maybe it's just
something you can grind out to and but
you know at least when you get them it's
actually kind of obvious about the Lord
you get like you know Ford's Lord number
one like you know complete five more
forges for something else like there'd
be at least like a checkbox or something
I still kind of don't even like that
idea but yeah just your way to find the
stories always obey it's always so
buried I mean first it was the grimoire
cards and now it's and stuff that you
have to orangy for at least the game or
cards and the hidden ghosts you could
literally go find them all if you want
to if I want to go grind them all out
people would make videos find them all
and you could knock him out at least
have the grimoire cards if you want him
but now it's just like cross my fingers
and hope I can't even like go to a
certain yeah it's ridiculous yeah that's
kind of whacking so just the fact I mean
they could have even been hidden in the
forges like you got to go over here and
you know find this thing scannable item
that could have been something fun to
find as opposed to just home you find
his sheet of paper in a run it's like no
shut up do mental he said literally what
you said he said believe and I miss
hunting for ghosts for info like you
know yeah I agree
oh yeah that's well the the rate goes up
now you can't farm it for free sand that
you actually just have to finish him it
says one in five but I sure as hell
haven't seen basically none and I
definitely done more than ten forges so
my brother's done a hell of a lot and he
still doesn't even have it done Jesus no
yeah my brother's my brother's got me on
that forge grind he's putting me to
shame
so yeah he's a be sad that wolf may do
anything out here more putting in the
time so after that so that tangent over
quest ups that require players to defeat
a high-value target on necess no longer
require player to land the final blow
again little pieces that just probably
Dean some QA checkin modulus reports and
ballistics logs will now go to post
master if lost thank God yes cap on
you'll support still say at 15 slightly
annoying kind of which that would be
bumped so if you want a farm you can and
then just keep like if I just want to
spend like let me spend an hour and is
it not you just go over and over and
over and burn it out be like then if I
get captain I don't pay attention I'm
not getting anymore it's like uh their
their artificial caps on whether its
glimmer like I can have five thousand
legendary shards but I can have fifteen
logs where where's the consistency yeah
is that consistent at all yeah so and
then Forge emblems will be awarded when
completing affords no longer requiring a
specific bounty to be completed so
that's just kind of a you know it's a
nimble and I'm not too concerned but
just gameplay type stuff it's like
they're headed there but then they make
some of these choices I'm like I know
they have to have reasons whether it's
like they want people to spend this much
time in that game or they want these
certain things but it's just like if you
really love your community some of the
stuff is not necessary yeah again a lot
a lot of a lot of lessons learned with
black armory on how to start this new
model you know so to speak it it's an
annual pass drip-feed kind of stuff
quote-unquote endgame kind of stuff so
yeah definitely lesson learned because
there was some things that if they just
corrected that you know quality of life
would have been so much better the
content would have been so much more
enjoyable and again yeah I gave I think
just onboarding and letting people know
how to do things and explain it in a
little better way would have been cool
yeah I mean shout out to Paul Tassie
because I know recently Cosmo has been
asking for feedback about gambit
obviously and Joker's wild is coming up
yes small testes like are you want my
feedback here you go and one of his big
ones and I think we've even said it
before and literally like explained
gambit to new people good okay so you're
gonna have the waves I mean he had a
couple ones about random spawns for
invaders sure invasion like crazy God
boat needs to be somewhat tweaked yeah
but it was just like for do people like
how many new people do you want to come
into destiny to hopefully all the time
right of somebody's like what's gambit
if you go and load in gammon you're like
okay I think I shoot these things these
things are dropping on the ground do it
do I take him to the middle unless you
go out and look on your own if you're
not gonna have an instruction booklet
for a game because it's not a cartridge
anymore you got to put some instructions
in the
game crucibles PvP you kind of explain
the mode some of that stuff like could
have a little more but gambit is a
unique little animal and you're like hey
you invade or when there's an invader
power level matters okay when you're
picking up motes don't be a dumbass and
carry too many when it would you have 74
go put them in the bank like de Graaff
what in turn is like what does that do
well if you do five it sends a small
blocker if you do ten it sends this when
you get to 75 you get your primeval like
if you hadn't seen that stuff and
there's new people out there they're so
lost and like that's one of those things
you want new people just a little bit of
training as to what the purpose is for
some of the stuff for some people they
have enough those little pop-ups be like
all Valor's live or iron banners live
hey you played your first match of
gambit this is how this works and having
clicked through like four screens and
then you're good like if you know what's
going on click click click look you're
done that doesn't take that long but on
the other side of somebody's new and be
like this is how you play gambit
holy crap some people might not suck
yeah so those are like that type of
thing they need and again this comes
back to Bungie wanting things to feel
good and worried about giving us too
much info but if you want new players to
come in not all of them and probably
many of them don't go look up YouTube
videos don't go to the Bungie blog much
less read the stuff that we're talking
about or listen to a destiny podcast so
huh yeah that's just like the little
pieces of when it comes to like the next
piece of this annual pass that you're
talking about you really need to be like
okay how do we make this experience good
for all make it a one-time thing or
something if you pull out gambit be like
hey let me hit whatever unnormal button
is not used and be like you know quick
overview or training or introduction and
if you fear done with it you don't ever
have to look in again but if you want to
look then you know yeah I agree man
totally nailed it I hit everything on
the head and it's again on like Tassie
said it best on boarding they have to do
a better job and I think they've learned
some lessons because I don't feel the
content we we will agree that we don't
feel the content terrible you know I'm
saying and we don't feel like the
drip-feed model is necessarily a bad
thing but there's just a way about
and then in terms of gambit new moles
you gotta explain
you gotta explain what to be done here
so that people are just not overwhelmed
so yeah I'm gonna greet me with that man
so what we got you Mike sorry even just
stuff like you know a PvP mode or
something be like hey it's like when I
log in and say hey this week the PvP the
weekly playlist is locked down or show
down I'm like I'm sorry what's the
distinction on that again it's like I
read it and I'm like I think I know
what's going on but I also feel like I'm
talking out of my butt
so there's certain things like that so
yeah they're just little tweaks that
could use a little of sometimes just
yeah helping out the newer players I
mean not everybody goes to YouTube
there's a lot of people be like I could
probably do a YouTube video for an hour
which somebody probably would not want
to spend some time on but like what is
new what's in here sure but again they
could do a little of that just listen at
the same time that's what we have he
bought is for to teach the masses I try
but if you don't want to teach we got it
but let's go this channel y'all you go
you learn you can learn a laugh you guys
have been awesome keep going so thank
you guys for this oh yeah so they also
said over the past few weeks members of
the community player support bungie.net
teams have been meeting to discuss some
ways we can improve the experience on
our forums so they just kind of go into
a little bit about the forums on
bungie.net which for a while has been
kind of a thing but most people go to
Reddit most people go to YouTube most
people go to you know their discord
chats and stuff like that so I mean
there's other places so they're trying
to kind of narrow down the basically the
Bungie forms to have a little bit more
useful places ago whether it's destiny
to feed Platt gameplay rewards and lore
mmm straightforward stuff that's go as
opposed to just kind of some other
things that seemed a bit more obscure so
they're just trying to organize the
Bungie forms they're trying to make you
know clan recruitment of things still
have a little bit over d1 but you know
it's kind of just out there stuff about
the companion player support stuff so
you just need to go all of its gonna be
planted right in there so
they're just trying to reorganize their
stuff and they're hopefully going to
load that lunch that stuff out next week
so it doesn't mean need to be too
in-depth but generally it just seems
nice that they haven't totally forgotten
because peanuts still thing like yes
it's been around forever and they still
try and curate it it's just it's not
where everybody goes but there's pretty
decent amount of traffic on there when
you look not the happiest people in the
world sometimes but they're there so
that one doesn't need a bunch yeah so
update two point one point four which
will be the 29th they have resolved
issues preview so this is what you guys
can expect to be fixed expected to be
resolved put that in quotes because
maybe not all but hopefully so we've got
the lost radiant matrix sometimes they
can become blocks from accessing black
armor activities so that'd be annoying
supposed to be fixed missing weapon
frames as they discussed so like they
just drop off available ones free to
purchase the mysterious box keys keys
are not sometimes applied when used for
the mysterious box but are removed from
inventory blocking progress oh yeah so
that's really not cool yeah be fixed but
it should actually be retro actively
applied which is good the fastidious
miser triumphs may sometimes not unlock
when you've done all the chests so
that's gonna be fixed full pursuits at
8:01 players not able to purchase weapon
frames when their pursuits inventory is
full receiving nothing while costing
materials again just these little checks
of things that are not quite working so
necessarily means just that thing where
it's the last touch on them earning read
Rick's broadsword is sometimes not
granted when completing its quests oh no
ya know no end and of course all these
things actually really matter than the
knife flippy makes me not go into like
actually many modes no I was sadly no
that's like my brother the first thing
you got thing is like why doesn't this
go infinite like now it's on the list so
apparently it's the thing oh oh whoa
your quality of life what was me Oh
monkey punch and cram in chat what's up
guys
so that is the stuff that is supposed to
be resolved on the 29th we still have
some things that are not yet to be
resolved and one of these is major the
black armory key molds only being
available on the first character to
receive it there's an issue with that
my brother is stuck in that moment now
while the knife he modes like a one
thing this actually affects your
gameplay on other characters your
progress on the quest so yeah that's a
major one and they still don't have a
date which is like guys come on yeah
like let's go relic Rumble trophy we're
investigating a issue where relic Rumble
doesn't unlock some machinist metal same
thing doesn't unlock is it because
nobody uses burden scope we are
investigating reports that the scope on
is an August Burton experiences issues
was well of Radiance inertia override
while invading game basically if you've
got an effect on you seems to screw with
the scope which not so fun so again like
how would you not test is izanagi's
burden in well radiance you know that
combination is gonna happen cuz it's
like god mode damage okay god mode
damage times - what's that gonna be like
you know that kind of tested yeah I
think for some reason yeah well
irradiance they Cana I noticed there's
always there's been a lot of these kind
of well over irradiance tweaks that
haven't been really tested out is
something new for them I guess I don't
know it was weird continued shadow epic
risk over in your kept for orange Jesus
just shining upon him yeah yards a
gallon or yotan ursa for OSA and another
one I'd mask with lay monarch I'm like
dude well I'm just gonna buy a small
roll for a minute or two but holy crap
that's insane like I'm just gonna give
him like my paw ball ticket and just let
him go to town just guest for me I mean
wall it's cool and then shout-out in my
chat to a mod for the for the sub thank
you very much for the high/low
appreciate that trust me all all you
guys a little support big support every
little bit counts trust me you guys have
no idea but every one of those matters
so much so thank you so yeah some the
big one is the key molds and that one
has got to get some work soon because my
brother's like he managed to start it
Hunter which is like the last character
he plays and his heightened his main one
but he can't do the black Armory whole
key question like on his other
characters and that's the only once it
done on so that's kind of a major on the
needs fix so hopefully that gets
addressed soon cross-agency got a couple
movies of the week apparently one of
them people just had fun with well of
Radiance but they were literally
stacking them on each other they had six
warlocks with all of Radiance and I
think they were stack him over and over
I heard one guy in like a little clip be
like I just got to nineteen like in a
row
they're just sharing orbs with each
other over and over and it's just like
broken so that was actually kind of a
funny montage because little difference
and then they wanted close out and say
we invite you to take a step back to
Friday January 11th 2019 Guardians have
been working together to solve the
puzzle and no no bee labs a final clues
given to nudge players in the right
direction after three and a half days a
huge a hubris of Niobe was recognized
and the puzzle was completed world's
first the Destiny community and I
honestly like glad was really pushing
this as well you know put up a video
world's first equals the community and I
only thought Niobe labs was like an odd
launch mechanic and I wish this was
something that was not locking afford so
it didn't quite get tarnished but the
way the community came together the
stuff going on in raid secrets because I
was watching some of that stuff live and
the time put in on trying to solve that
thing was like you had NASA code
breakers going in you had the level of
people go into town I mean this is the
community coming together yeah
absolutely I just wanted to salute all
of that stuff so absolutely that was
really cool to see everybody just try to
crank it with coming together it's
always fun when you get those kind of
moments in destiny yeah for sure so I
know that kind of wraps up this week for
the world of destiny but what about you
feel like I was just talking for a
minute what's your feeling about all the
stuff whether it's the sandbox some of
the fixes come in we got supers changing
what do you think coming on the twenty
more are you looking I feel good I feel
good I like I love you know me when I
hear sandbox I get excited I get you
know I get all warm inside man that
means that they're tweaking that means
they're looking at stuff you know I mean
they look and I like when they're saying
they're
looking at underutilized things now we
got to get back to the armor again guys
remember the armor we got exotic armor
it out there that need tweaking too so
don't forget that and I don't want them
to forget also you know they started
with this one they doing you know a
curious Telesto and what was the third
one arm which go long was it there when
they did today so accurate Celeste oh
and one other exotic that they they said
they were gonna touch but at the end of
the day it comes down to listen you had
travels and so Hartman yeah so you know
that's cool but at the end of the day is
like they they definitely have to
continue that you know III miss that
update like when they did what was it
like a graviton number you know sunshine
like they gotta continue to do stuff
like that that really reinvigorates life
so I'm good to see the actress got some
love we'll see how effective it is but
yeah overall I'm good with all this I
like archetype buffs you know we still
gotta find something to do with
submachine guns and like you said on
sidearms we still gotta do something
with that but uh overall you know I
can't get too crazy and you know I just
also want to know I'm actually one of
the win is um I know we could talk about
traveling when is faction rallies coming
back man like some of that
I mean faction really catalyst for one
like somebody's like new 100 days since
faction rally catalysts were a thing
that we're supposed to be like here
we're gonna find a way to put him back
in mmm-hmm they're still not even
mentioned I mean I know that's not
probably a high priority for like free
catalysts but even tasks it was like
dude where the hell is the rest of my
catalysts so many weapons now don't even
have them there's no mention of them
coming back armor really doesn't have
them so I mean catalysts are a big thing
to like there's a lot of things as you
said faction release trials catalysts
catalysts were a grind that made war
mind a thing yeah so they're leaving
some stuff on the table right now and I
know the world is up in the air they're
juggling about 6,000 balls because I
mean they're on their own and stuff like
that but there's there's some things
that they need to not forget about
to continue like the progress they've
made they don't they can't just like the
can't pull a d1 obviously do you want to
d2 they can't do a complete like flop
and reset and just make everything kind
of trash for a minute but in turn the
things that they were adding in and like
the evolution of exotics to have the
catalyst was really really cool but then
they just kind of like they stopped yeah
and that thing can't get away from they
cannot get away from that because as
we're about to get into the competition
is coming it we are at the end of
January and February is approaching we
got one on route that is a lot of
excitement and then in March we got
another game that is coming that has a
lot of excitement so yeah this is the
time to really start reintroducing
things keeping that interest level
having people still talk about your game
now grant it you can't do anything on
launch there's always gonna be that
excitement period for a new game that's
just how of course you know I mean but
at the end of it at the end of the day
if you start getting your base preparing
that other big things are coming back
then it's like okay I'm a rock out here
for a little bit but I know you know
this he's gonna do this or whatever
whatever they need to get that going I
mean I'm not saying that they don't I
know their plate is full with all the
Activision split but it's not much time
turnaround time to start focusing so
like you said a pressure cooker they
gotta get it poppin let's go so shall we
get into it yeah so if you guys are
gamers and you like the Luther shooter
space there's no way you haven't heard
of either of these but we are gonna
start with the one that comes sooner
mmm-hmm wrong order anthem yes
Oh anthem is definitely going to be a
thing now some of you guys may wonder
like what the hell's anthem some of you
may not care some of you guys may be
like it's Bioware it's EA I don't trust
them I don't know and there's a lot of
questions out there it's a completely
new IP which does have some appeal going
for it because a brand new IP still has
the wonder of what could this be
what does it have to offer will it be
good will it last over time there's a
lot of questions up in the air
but I just want to get your feel from
you know what you've seen in videos and
what you've kind of experienced from you
know talking to different people and
things like that right what are your
thoughts about this just from you know
30,000 foot perspective what's the big
high view um listen you know full
disclosure obviously I have experienced
it um the thing is that people have to
understand is that I think I will shout
out to our erics gaming cuz I've had him
on a podcast before and I remember we
had a topic and it was kind of like you
know anthem versus division versus
destiny who wins the big war caliphate
right so at that time you know I'm a
Bioware fanboy and at that time I was
told to me hey they're not gonna be
doing the the typical Bioware choices
and relationship kind of storytelling
that Bioware is known for so that kind
of got me depressed
then I heard oh you know no pvp at
launch right something like yeah that
got me a little depressed by then I saw
it at arm III Microsoft press conference
maybe two years ago when they revealed
it and everything looked amazing I'm not
going that revealed looked fantastic but
a part of me being a good being that I
go to a lot of eateries you know you
always used to sometimes seeing
something on screen for the first time
and you get that what I quote unquote
vertical slice right so I'm like is that
the game or you didn't say like what are
those things so I didn't I just didn't
want to trust them because it what they
show look great but I'm like I deal is
to say what else want to much that is
the game that is the game and I think
this thing is going to have a big effect
on people right I think graphically oh
boy you know I mean it is it is really a
looker it is different from what the
other two are doing um you know as far
as the javelins you got you know a nice
mix the speed of the game's nice it's
really cool um ultimately
I think now it comes down to you know
what the gate the basic gameplay
mechanic is how that's implemented and
then after my only concern with anthem
is after you get through campaign it are
they gonna have that hook are they're
gonna have that end game and I've seen
some videos on this I shot the Game
Informer they did a really good one and
they talked about um you know like I
guess they had they have something I've
got I've got that the terminology but um
it's it's it's kind of it's in-game but
it's kind of not so I was low concerned
about that but then they asked me to
longer strongholds thank you thank you
yeah so um they see you and I said you
know those things for us to do and then
they talk about difficulty scaling all
that stuff sounds great you know I'm
getting a Diablo kind of vibe right now
one negative that I heard that I'm not a
fan of is if we are in the mission
together and our the game scales which
is cool so you know someone's playing a
long time that's fine you know but the
thing I didn't like is that like we beat
the boss and there's a drop it's just
like legendary you cannot go into your
menu and see what that is until you go
back to that base of for tarsus yeah
whatever so that I got to see how that
plays in so basically when you go out
with your loadout onto a mission that's
your loadout it's almost the equivalent
there's not even a lock screen you just
cannot get into I guess the game wants
you just to focus on the game and not
pausing and checking there you're not
switching weapons mid run or anything
like that you are going out with a build
exactly so again how are people gonna
take to that that's another thing and
then ultimate just gonna be the end game
I think it's gonna be the one of those
things that for people who have an issue
with destiny not having a good lore and
all that stuff and people who are very
PvE focus I think they're gonna
gravitate towards I think it's gonna
make a strong impression my only concern
is the legs how long will it last and
then you know we'll give it to the other
game but I want your impressions of
anthem like what you've seen what you've
experienced you know where where are you
at you know would anthem in general so
for me anthem is gonna be scratching a
slightly different
just because of a more specialist
feeling classes it's something I've
asked for destiny maybe the rumors we
hear about destiny 3 being more of an
RPG maybe there's a little more going
there and cross my fingers it is but the
each a guardian is a guardian now
they're gonna have different abilities
yeah they have different feels but
really if you're like I mean your
resilience those things don't really
matter that much you can all generally
play a field now we do have the well of
radius for kind of a healer you do have
the wall shield for a bit of that but I
mean generally you don't have aggro you
don't have anything to that nature that
you really can play off of the way you
would I mean a memo well the Warcraft or
anything of that nature so when you have
something as as big of a disparity as
two javelins from the chap from the
Colossus to the Interceptor alone but
also the storm those two and the Rangers
kind of fallen in the middle will
actually have more you actually have
roles because the Colossus is gonna be
your big-ass shield tank guy literally
taunting enemies to be like hey look at
me I'm down here let that other leave
that other guy alone so you can melt you
from above like there's a different role
and different play type of what's gonna
happen in this game because you going in
a clausus and you play it poorly you can
screw your team over if you're not
taunting you're not doing damage you're
not getting the walls that you need but
in turn if you do it well you're gonna
give those other DPS errs and it's
really gonna have those types of roles a
chance to succeed so there's gonna be a
different set of hey what is Mike my
brother straight-up gonna be a colossus
he's gonna walk I'm gonna be the big
huntin tank oh I got shield in there I
mean yeah it fits you know fit but
that's his role that's what he wants to
do and he's been waiting for something
like that me I'm torn between the storm
in the Interceptor because one has the
elemental afar damage kind of putting
combos together the other one the
interceptors up in the battle in out in
out quick like movements so they feel
different and I think that's one of the
biggest things that destiny needs a bit
more to its Guardians like that's why
when we I was probably 6 months ago when
we were talking about this crap like the
hunter if I say there's four hunters
that go like full-on like full mobility
they should probably have less health
than lie
okay slow walking Titan and you should
be able to feel that but it's like if
you got you know four nimble you know
hunters jumping around holy crap they
might over on the Titans but if those
Titans are just you know sitting there's
beastly tanks that you know huffing out
your chest and they're just sitting
there be like come on bring it I got I
got health for days like that's a
completely different playstyle and
that's something I wish that Bungie
would lean a little harder into it's
like they got the first-person shooter
now you got to make those play styles
actually feel different so that's one of
the biggest things for me now your feel
about Diablo is probably spot-on because
those of you haven't played Diablo you
got your normal difficulties like normal
hard nightmare okay that's probably like
gonna be same thing with anthem easy
normal part whatever and then you have
these other levels like once you're like
okay what the hell is the end game have
well you take the same content and then
you throw insanity one on top and then
insanity two and you take it to another
level and that's where you start getting
some of those masterwork drops that
they've got you've got the legendaries
which are like their exotics and you
start making it harder content and
that's where for again how much of a
diablo is it gonna feel like am i gonna
run the same dungeon over and over is
there gonna be any randomness to these
things right I'm gonna go run the same
stronghold six different times at a
higher difficulty level get one new
piece get some different gear and then
I'm gonna crank the difficulty up again
but I'm back doing the same strongholds
like that's where how much of the
repetition now saying repetition in the
world of destiny empowering a kettle
black like it's yeah we all do it how
many times have our own the Dreaming
City how many strikes and night falls
have I done yes we all play that stuff
over and over that's a looter shooter um
but it's kind of like what is gonna be
what piece of this content do you enjoy
do you enjoy the third-person where you
know you're gonna have your different
type of feels you're gonna have like an
auto rifle where it's just a machine gun
with continuous bullets there might be
some faster and slower ones there is
sniper rifles I've seen footage of that
so you've got some scopes or you can
actually do that and then you're gonna
have some more like shotguns and bursts
and pulses but you're not gonna have
that intimate feel with a first-person
weapon and oh it's one of the pieces
where that's a preference in play style
yeah I like the feel of you
weapon do you like that you know
pinpoint accuracy of move it around or
is it just I'm firing in the general
direction door toward a dude and I'm not
going for like I'm gonna shoot him in
the shoulder blade as opposed to I'm
gonna shoot him in the upper body so I
think there's the level of precision
that we'll be lacking in this and it's
it's one of those things that it's gonna
have a very different feel and it may
and that's we'll get to the other game
here in a little bit but that's it's a
it's gonna be a very different game like
I mean it's a Loutre shooter but they're
about as far apart yeah in some aspects
as you can get yeah I mean I think you
pretty much nailed it too because I
think it's just different right so it's
gonna appeal to a different audience the
question comes down to how many people
like you said prefer that playstyle
versus you know one thing we know
destiny by far has the best gunplay in
video gaming like that it's just it's
not even close like I mean the way
things feel the way Bungie does
first-person shooting it's just it's
just another level you know the vibe I
got from anthem it's not necessarily
that's their foundation they're more on
these abilities you know I'm saying the
verticality of the game the different
classes that kind of stuff
you know I mean so they're going for a
whole different thing and again I think
if the story driven stuff is done well
that will appeal to people who love a
nice heavy narrative you know I mean so
they've got some things going for them
you know I'm very curious because
according to one of the devs I think
it's about they're saying
a short time after release is when they
will get um you know some type of you
know raid content you know what they are
considering endgame I don't know what
that is half the notice because again
they have to be careful this thing can
start off with a bang galvanize the
masses and we saw kind of what happened
to division 1 right yeah we're getting
married yes indeed it started like I
mean destiny my destiny friendless
betrayed me he they Wendy Wendy version
one came out that was right right around
during the drought
I think post taking King and next year
that thing dropped and I was like man
Manhattan ice run it had a good run but
once you maxed then it became okay you
know what was it you know for some a lot
of people the incursians wasn't enough
and we'll transitions in division very
shortly but um Adam definitely has to
prove that that's it so I'll give it to
you while the cops are you know my block
make it up sirens going on fire
department and police let's go you know
good work out there they were my boys
good yeah I mean that's kind of the big
thing is I mean Division will get to
Division two on a very different reason
Division one I mean started great level
1 through 30 level enough doing each
mission as you go through the
progression was solid and by the time
you kind of finished it you'd hit Beck's
level there was the whole min maxing I
mean the dark zone got to a point of
being overrun by people throat like just
try and if we righted there was no there
was no like level separation they
finally added that later they had the
survival they had the random dungeon
thing underneath which they added stuff
later but it's like how fast do people
leave games now is Justin
oh it's fast like I mean some people are
gonna hang on longer some people don't
but that's I mean the same thing you're
saying it's like is it going to turn
into a Diablo like dungeon 3 for level
17 like I mean whatever whatever they
call it
Diablo it's like how high do you crank
those up there is no PDP definitely not
at lunch they've sittin down maybe later
but they've said absolutely zero PvP at
lunch
would you have some upsides you can have
absolutely busted PvE weapons and it's
not going to matter so it lets you have
a little more flexibility and developing
crazy stuff and things like that it's
gonna be a different like build style
though because you're still gonna have
take like your perks on a weapon well
those are gonna be your perks on certain
pieces of gear the more rare the more
perks that you can have on it which is
kind of cool but the main thing is kind
of your build you're gonna have two
weapons for most and then you've got
your options of abilities so if you guys
take I'll go to the basic I'll go to
your Ranger you're gonna have your
abilities
segment zoom in so you guys can see this
us your weaponry on the javelin so all
of the three except the Colossus is
gonna be capable every weapon type
except for heavy weapons and Colossus is
vice-versa for every weapon but light
weapons like little stuff then you're
gonna have a melee ability you're gonna
have a grenade and then you're gonna
have your different pieces of gear so
your mail is just gonna be melee each
character will just straight-up come
with her melee
they have to have one but then you've
got loadouts and all the way your gear
drops in this game is gonna be based on
the gear you have determines what you
can do it's not like you go into destiny
and you unlock a perk tree and be like
hey I'm gonna go solar grenade I'm gonna
go solar build I'm gonna pick this
grenade it's a different setup to
different so you're gonna be you're
gonna get a frag grenade inferno frost
seeker or sticky those are your
different grenades and then you've got
your launcher homing missiles energy
poles spark beam venema darts blast
missile and then you have your support
gear bulwark point which is like a
spherical field which deflects incoming
projectiles muster point and those are
the other three things you can equip so
literally you're gonna have like bulwark
point maybe you get a rare bulwark point
that drops with perks that give you you
know extra defense while you're on the
ground cool that's like a 1 then you get
a masterwork one that has three
different perks on it plus the other one
so that one's even better but it's still
just that point so the idea is you're
building your javelin to have its
abilities but you're not gonna have
you're not gonna have you know different
types of grenades different types of
supers it's a different setup and it's
like once you kind of figure out like
okay do I like the infernal grenade okay
then I just want the one infernal
grenade role but that's like that's my
place now that's my goal and then your
launcher you're gonna get different
launchers as you go but once you narrow
it down I I wonder about the longevity
of the way you build your your javelin
now you can play all four you're not
limited so like you have a pilot and you
can pick each one and you got loadouts
for each one but it will be interesting
to see how much variety it feels like or
if it's like if I'm gonna go play on my
ranger I just know how it's going to
play there doesn't reveal
as much customization when we have like
three complete subclasses that really do
feel different in destiny yeah yeah I
agree I agree
yeah these good points man I can't wait
like I said the excitement is there for
the game we we have our concerns
obviously you know I mean we'll see how
they do this is the first up to bat and
then we got something else right yeah
some other game we've also got it's the
sequel to the one we've been talking
about in the division no I was rambling
my butt off about anthem but what's your
thoughts on just a sequel to the
division first off um this is the game
that I am most concerned about and when
I say concern not in the negative one
concerned as the threat because here's
the thing why my thing right now is that
I feel like Evan has the flash but maybe
the vision might have the long-term
substance and the only reason why I say
is because we all know how this game
launched it started off tremendously you
know everyone's playing this game very
addicted to it's a different style you
know more of the you know the tactical
MMO kind of thing it's really cool
everybody liked it and there's cars
again okay fine
okay but home at the end of the day you
know it came down to that end game it
came down to the longevity you know and
seeing if people stuck around and
massive to me seem like they learned a
lot you know I'm saying and especially
in games so when I first tried to sort
of trailer raid on my wall okay they
they're focusing on it's not gonna be
just those excursion thing because to be
honest I wasn't really a fan of that the
excursion thing you know um as far as
customization as far as the mid maxing
as far as abilities
I felt division really had that down as
far as the dark zone was I see that that
was a struggle yeah I wouldn't
I'ma be real like I wasn't a fan of
dudes in there trolling just cuz you
know life in the game and one shot knob
or like so those things were it was a I
liked the idea of the mold right but I
just didn't feel it was implemented
properly now since then they've had
subsequent upgrades and they've
definitely done a lot since and I
actually like the survival or DLC when
they had a little taker and I thought
that was really cool yeah it was like a
like a morel basically like the tweak on
it yes so the dog zone was in my bag now
as I've been getting in from them and
paying attention a lot to division
obviously got the story trailer this
week right I'm sore that got the
Washington DC the whole thing I thought
the narrative was decent you know saying
now mind you I've played both games it
was a play division at which cover I
came away from it is if you love
division you gonna love this one
the key now is like I said the end game
and all that stuff now I just got some
information on the dark zone they just
put something out there maybe I could
dare to and I'm actually intrigued II
cuz they had it the way they stored it
now they're talking about three dark
zones yeah man they had arm you know one
kind of based on long-range combat one
kind of based on short-range combat the
other one kind of like a mix and then
they also doing this thing the main
thing that they're doing it does own
that I like and I know the hardcore
division doesn't might not like this is
they are evening the playing field when
you step in there so there's no more oh
I'm level 75 i low-life that here come
these noobs let's go get them that's
over with everyone's now added equal
footing and it comes down to the skill
and your twitch skills as far as the
killing so they added that they added
some turrets to stop people from camping
at small points or whatever they was
doing and and grieving people again this
is how you get another Hong Kong may not
like it but no casual player is going in
there getting robbed getting this stuff
taken you know and then you know talk
about a this is a great time like no
one's doing that consistent because this
was their nd they thought was there
at the time you know I'm saying so oh
shout out to Beantown Plus Spanky you
love this poor guys guys keep up thank
you so much for AI means a lot thank you
thank you for listening to the last word
so um gaming so we had that aspect so I
heard that way then to appease the
hardcore they're doing a wrote about
took me three dark zones they're doing a
rotating dark zone that has the old way
so like say for example this week on in
you know DC in Georgetown you're I'm
saying part of the tent like this is the
dark zone where the level matters so I
thought that's cool because it's like it
introduces dawgzone and actually Danzo
is part of the storyline as well so when
you play the game the game is gonna take
you to each of these dark zones to give
new players a feeling of how things are
that they needed to do because to be
honest when I'm that devout was scared
to death the run I'm not getting robbed
out there you're not taking muster I did
if the scariest [ __ ] division if you've
ever played the dogs only thing is
shooting that flare up it is like hey
guys I'm here on the corner 3456 blue I
was like it was a cool moment like there
were things in that but we're awesome
and also terrifying but yeah okay okay
good right obviously they got um you
know a I in there as well you know it's
a different type of tension you think
but I think the way they're handling it
I'm coming around a little bit eating
this last stream I think you're shouting
Marcos who it is we got it in the ILP
disc or if you check out our podcast
discord check out I mean Lords of
diamond disco excuse me um check out the
division channel and I'll shout out
trouble l-boogie Snell no they've been
putting stuff up they're updating and I
got a chance in slow-mo you got a chance
to check that stuff and I really like
they also have a dedicated PvP mode did
not expect that
um and then the last thing is we've
confirmed because at e3 they confirmed
on the Ubisoft stage there are raids not
incursions thank you for correcting that
keep call them excursions they give you
a incursions alright that's interesting
to me so again I think short-term anthem
a while the masses but my prediction is
long-term division may keep you playing
and the last point but now give it to
our number rambling free DLC right that
that's a factor
you're not splitting the base like man
like I'm worried as a destiny but that's
the game cuz date number they started
off as the new kid on the block and
let's keep it real desk defense they
punch destiny in a mall fat launch
everybody was I seen destiny content
creators going making division channels
remember that mmm-hmm everyone was like
yo this is the wave now I stood true cuz
I know which game I liked a little bit
better it was a bottom at the end of the
day I have to recognize the power of
that game then they fade it off and
obviously we know what happened now they
got in game they got all these moles
they got this stuff you know they have a
little bit of it they have a narrative
it'll be interesting man like I know
you're I know we've talked about
division
but like give me your personal feelings
of the first game and then from what
you're hearing and what you're seeing
about division to where you kind of at
with division
partially so the first one I play the
hell out of beta and that was one of the
first things that was on my channels
honestly a little bit a little bit of
it's where I started so division has
trying to think the best way to say this
has some of the things I really like
they went deeper into the numbers they
went but you actually see the damn
numbers which destiny just absolutely
hates doing which frustrates me if I
throw a rampage on there tell me what
the hell that does by the way I page
back on something it adds a second to
your rampage don't make us go make
youtube videos to figure it out
so the clarity on that is nice but
there's a piece about division that also
can limit it now leveling up one two
thirty I loved like going around in the
city running in New York and the wit
that has got to be the best cover system
feeling like I know or the joke about
closing the door but it was really the
way it felt like if I run up to a corner
of walk cool if I peek out cool if I'm
up to like a car it never felt like the
cover sucked like Oh hover it was better
than almost any other game I played
there third-person cover systems just
nothing could touch it it was so good so
I mean the way that felt made the tackle
encounter is kind of cool like you could
like you know use some of your abilities
to catch them off and then as you work
through you know snipers and things got
to be kind of cool working from range
doing the dark zone and then you kind of
got to the top point and you're like
okay so how much time am I gonna spend
trying to go for endgame the time you
put in versus what you got out of it or
you got robbed in the dark zone and that
was the only place to level up and they
forced you into the dark zone on the
first day and and just there were so
many trolls so many people running as
groups getting hard over the risk of
doing it and after a while it's just
like do I really want a headache of like
trying to bash my head against thirty
minutes on fighting some big boss
sponges which I'll talk about in a
second and then maybe have it just
ripped away and that was that was a
really really tough thing because in the
in-game if I really want to be able to
try and level up I need a way to do that
or I don't have the risk of just getting
screwed mm-hmm I agree that was the
thing now the other piece for me about
division that takes away some of the fun
and this is where anthem has some appeal
and so does that so there you go it's
the division is so tied to realism so
what you can do in it not a bad way I
mean if you like guns you like your
tactical shooters you like your scopes
and your barrels and all that stuff but
then when you have still a dude who
takes six thousand bullets to die you're
like okay that doesn't make as much
sense as here's this giant space Oh gird
Ark magic thing yeah I guess probably
gonna take a few bullets because you
brochures you know shooting crazy large
animals and then just like bounces off
same situation like it's gonna take some
work like another do
I don't care how he's wearing at some
point that stuff gives out I got a vac
yo so you try to tell me you don't like
shooting dudes with the red hoodie 35
times a day bad drop that's a hell of a
kevlar hoodie I mean it just feels like
it's doing some good work out there I
just gotta get me one of those cuz ya be
safe to walk around in that hoodie for
life mm-hmm so what's those limitations
and it really just depends on how it
feels
um the guns felt pretty good I mean
Destiny's still personally it's
first-person verse third so again a
preference of what you like I mean the
guns kind of felt cool they definitely
had distinct guns I mean they had their
own meta in there you had I mean some of
the mods that you could put on there
some of the like gear sets they got into
gear sets that's cool yeah why the hell
doesn't he can't get a gear set going on
like oh come on they not like about
division when there's still ahead of the
curve when it comes to that mid max net
customization to every piece of gear can
customize and go towards a build and
give you a positive rating towards a
skill and I like that about and the I
forgot about the gear sets they added
all that stuff when I stopped playing
right this tons of people to hardcore
division players no shelter neo mental
in here shelter PD in here like as the
game went on you know that game really
got good and it's just that the base was
already done at that but the casual base
was through with the game at that point
but this and I want to give it right
back to you but I also want to comment I
forgot another mode that I really like
that I hope they bring back is survival
I don't know if you have a play survival
mode I played like a couple times but
yeah I like the concept but it felt like
you know you have to do things to stay
alive keep warm that whole thing it was
like you almost almost on a ticking
timer kinda I hope they bring that
little thing back as a thing but I'll
give it back to you in terms of your
points you were finishing that with the
realism aspect and the other things you
were going into yeah so I mean it's just
like so you take like a destiny raid and
you're like okay this is gonna be big
it's fallen in the lost city or you have
the Dreadnought and you're facing
against Oryx and you got the taken realm
you can go sci-fi insanity
anthem has that bonus going because I
mean they're out there there's the
anthem like the life changing power you
got flying Iron Man suits of different
classes you got crazy you know monsters
and stuff that you're fighting you got
the verticality and this is like this is
all grounded in Washington DC you're on
a level now they had like a couple
buildings you could go up floors in and
I know it would be harder to do but one
of the things about division that I wish
and I know it's hard to program I'm not
a game maker and it's it's a it's a big
ask and I don't expect it but the
verticality like if every building you
go into in say the dark zone had
different levels and different floors
and you can go in and hide in a building
and peek out all the windows and
everything was actually interactive not
just mostly the streets here's like
three buildings you can go in but most
of them is just the outside like you can
actually spend some time in interiors
almost have a little toying around with
something like a pub G field where every
building is able to be entered in
explored and hiding in and stuff like
that that would give it a little more
variety at least as opposed to just run
in the streets of New York or run the
streets of DC now which while could be
cool and different scenery change is
fine but you've got even less
verticality so now you're gonna be
running through like open fields mm-hmm
yeah it'd be interesting I will say this
and I think we have to we can't
understate rates for them
ya know I'm very 8 man rates I'm here
yeah go ahead that's and apparently this
is supposed to be the super hardcore
in-game content they've really
supposedly done there or I got a chance
to speak to the devs about you know
obviously couldn't release much to me at
that point everything still you know but
you know they were saying they were
there you know and they plan on that
post-launch content of Ray's being a
major component of destiny
now if they I mean that's the division
you don't say now if they're able to you
know if they're able to get if that's an
exciting thing that I guess you know
I'll just need from them I just need
mechanics it just can't like I was
literally like dude it just can't be
waves or the hoodie waves of this dude
next waves or that like it can't be that
cuz that to me was what the incursians
was I wasn't feeling its
have to be we have to do see that's
people don't understand people can crown
destiny say what they want best gun
mechanics and best and there's nothing
no other game in my opinion is beating
destiny when it comes to endgame do you
know what it is to do well just argue
with a pop that's me so good when you
arguing about which rage are the best
that's where we are going pyro going out
of there as well Oh me shout the power
even though he's insane with his crota
ranking but we ain't gonna get into it
that's mommy I like fire but ho he's got
last where's a lot of dust on Dalton
glass I'm just gonna say that ah you all
first one at tu brute a we could listen
we're gonna do a special last word I
better get is gonna be Pyro's gonna be
on I'm gonna get baby addict in the
all-male sinister I'm looking for you
I'm just gonna go sit in the bathroom a
bucket of popcorn and mute my microphone
I'm not even gonna be in that mix he has
accepted the show he's gonna be on it
we're gonna do a show it's gonna be
about that's destiny raids ranking the
rates you know saying and we're gonna
talk about but all this crow to talk
don't stop but anywhere as long as short
of it back to division is that that is
what destiny does splitting the people
up teams of two doing mechanics figuring
out secrets I just struggled to car say
okay how is division doing that in a
game based on real but yeah I wanna give
him a shot you know I'm willing to see
if they they've got stay cooking up
something you know we'll see we'll see
but that's the thing that a destiny
player is not going to leave for
division until division proves it can do
something like that yeah I mean that's
go ahead last point if division has a
king's fall or a you know rafter the
machine style thing you know that
whatever faction or whatever it is and
they doing that and then hey all bets
are off now we're talking about who's
fighting for the crown
if they able to do something like that I
just want to know if they if they
elevate it to that level that's the
question and that's the hard part I mean
you take an anthem raid you gotta have
like mechanics you could have this thing
that you've gotta freeze you got
somebody who's coming with like
corrosive build you got you have to dot
this guy to drop his shield so you have
damage over time going you bust out a
super and then I'm sitting there running
around with yeah I might have a sniper a
shotgun and maybe a heavy machine gun
and I might have this little drone and
stuff but even the super like the
special abilities are like you have your
specializations and what they're going
that's what it feels anthem so you've
got survivalist demolitionist and
sharpshooter and you've got survivalist
is gonna have their precision crossbow
oK you've got the demolicious it looks
like he's got they've got a grenade
launcher she does and then sharpshooters
of course a sniper rifle but I mean how
that's a you're saying it perfect it's
like how can you really make another
encounter cuz I mean you think about the
last mission in Division one where you
go against the helicopters and you've
got the final group of those heavy
military guys that you're going through
some of them are tough you've got the
outside fight I'm like that felt kind of
cool but it was like how much farther
can you take something realistic in in
division like how far can you take it
out there and make as a as what as a few
people on the ground unless you start I
mean we fought a tank in a box I that it
was bad literally right we've had like
the few drones the few dudes and you
walking it was just a skill box of this
thing just just wanted to destroy you're
acting you're like I'm just a dude and
they're in like an 8 like a yeah I can't
even think the right terminology for the
vehicle but it was just like they're
sitting there in a small concrete
underground room not a lot of room and
it just explosions going on which would
probably make you all deaf anyway like
the realest if they go for realism but
then they detach and then your guy
trying to shoot a ship and you got a run
up and put the solar source on the side
and try and go back and it was and God
just did not feel great and after what a
PC thank you so given
and how's ochi yeah both you guys got
about the same trash oh so that's why
the things that they did for the random
underground stuff that you could do and
you could crank up the modifiers that
was a good idea survival aspect gave you
something to do where everybody is on
the same level and gave you a little bit
of that battle royale which was kind of
nice to like those things that came
later work good but like again is this
one of those things do they pull a d1
they they have a campaign and then they
have like your specializations but that
other content the random dungeons the
things that d1 people really enjoyed is
that gonna take another year to come
back into they are they gonna pull
anyone because they haven't mentioned
any of that crap so what you mean b1 in
what sense - Gabe brace anyone like are
they gonna pull destiny one where they
throw half the stuff that we liked out
and then they have to take some time and
bring it all back cuz like oh I see what
you're going okay I gotcha
yeah it's Division one gonna have all of
those features that is Division two can
have all the features that d1 is it
gonna have survival is I'm gonna have
the randomness they've got the PDP
they've got I mean they've got a
survival is coming back I felt like that
was a special DLC [ __ ] I mean at launch I
meant to say that's it oh but I got to
feel like that was a special boat that
was added later in the game but or
launch day I mean are in their defense
they've got a lot of different
activities at launch I mean cuz you got
your basic game you got your campaign
you got you got your PvP you got your
gone got further you got dark zone and
you got PvP so yeah that's the thing
already off top they got over and them
because it when anthem starts and you
play and you beat that campaign and
they're saying well they speak to the
DES I keep saying older their endgame
post you're not the stronghold is you
know coming soonish what does that mean
you know I mean like again if people
blaze the content and finish it's gonna
die I don't care how hot the game is I
don't care how great the game look it's
going to die so they have to get that
squared away they may have the story
over the vision I'll give them that
Casey Hudson those guys narrative
characters all that we got
but watching the story tailor for
division they didn't seem that shabby I
liked the Washington DC setting you know
I want to see how they build that whole
thing up but I think at launch d
Division two has the edge as far as
things you can do to keep you invested
as a player I will give them that it is
my no no I mean I think you're I think
you're right and that's the and that's
the thing I mean cut about Sue's even
saying that there and chat about anthem
is like if they go the Diablo route it's
just a different it's a different style
of game completely like if you're
working on men Mac so you're gonna take
this one ok let's crank this up to level
12 like then you just go to you know
insanity and then if you keep going and
building and trying to get to that meta
and you're working on getting your score
gear score to the max so anything cuz
they both actually have your scores I'm
sure games are gonna run that way so
power level gear score it's all the same
thing
so all those things are gonna be and
it's they may honestly not overlap as
much it just depends on what style you
enjoy because that's kind of the if
anthem feels very Diablo ish and then
divisions goes like co-op hardcore
rating like that type of stuff they they
may not be as they may have some
separation I mean of course they're all
gonna compete because people only have
so much time goodbye all of my sleep if
I can try oh my god seriously like
whether it's like gambit stuff and
quests coming out I mean I can almost
thank God the Destiny's gonna if I feel
like be at a quiet time because there's
gonna be a little bit of story there's
gonna be some game but stuff but I don't
have to go full out on that one because
yeah there's gonna be other stuff to do
oh yeah no absolutely rough absolutely
yeah be so let's let me let me put your
feet to the fire yeah alright we're
gonna do our first one from the left
based on the information that we have
thus far no they're on anthem and
Division I need the last word on what
you're getting what's you more excited
to play right now we'll put your spot
last words
let's go but she will citement versus
expectation or two different things
excitement I'm gonna leave anthem cuz it
is new mmm it is new it's vertical you
get to be Iron Man there's something
like that everybody gets to be Iron Man
you get different varieties you got the
Hulkbuster you got I mean you got
different options I've I feel like I
kind of know what to expect with
division ok I see where you going ok
feels like I know it's just depends on
how they execute but I know I've played
Division 1 I can understand it's gonna
be tactical missions on city streets and
it's down-to-earth with guns and you
level up and and I'm looking forward to
it but excitement and optimism is for
the unknown that's my way to phrase it
because division has established a lot
of things and if they execute on the
launch well they've got a chance of
being a very very solid game anthem is
the big thing up in the air and nobody
knows till it lands till we actually see
what we got I mean the demo is gonna
hopefully tell a lot long reaching your
chest said both Laurel reef that's not
fair this is the last word I had to
challenge you got a challenge you I want
the one it's nobody did it
I gave you one you know y'all I'm T I'm
teasin what about you o flip-flopping
bro I've been flip-flopping if you spoke
to me two weeks ago in a bit of
different answers but divisions calling
me is so weird I don't know why I'm the
guy that probably is so hard on that
game and I think I think my
sensibilities lean towards customization
I think my sense you haven't given me an
answer yet because both of them do that
but I feel that division yeah again it's
earlier we were talking about we're told
the last word as of right now based on
the information this is going to
fluctuate as we get closer to release
for both games right yeah the demo for
the demo is gonna tell me a lot
right Adams the demos come in we're
gonna learn a lot right the bay that's
what we're gonna learn last so this
again we're just talking about as of you
know January 18th
like that's maybe clear doesn't this is
not much this is not your final state is
not my final statement you know saying
but yeah shout to Christopher Hart I
think they're gonna correct all the
mistakes named but that's that see
they've been there before there's
something to be said when you put out
your first effort it does well then you
kind of fade and people a bit like you
learn from that and I for some reason
I'm saying you know what they may learn
from it and I just think for me
personally the two things that got him
excited is I am NOT a dark zone person I
am now excited to go into the dark zone
you know I'm curious about what the rate
is I want to do gear sets I want to see
you know what maxing out a build is the
drones or whatever the stuff they got
the different types and classes they got
you know am i thrilled about shooting
dudes with hoodies in the face is
probably not as much like anthem has
that initial excitement so I'm with you
and that like anthem has more excitement
to play I'm just worried about does that
wear off but anthem could surprise
anthem could really show yo we got meat
we got legs we got things to do you're
gonna see that we haven't even shown you
know but as of right now based on this
week's information of division stuff you
know I got a I gotta say division right
now but you know we got there was a
stream for anthem yesterday that I still
gotta watch my brother so that's pretty
good yeah so what's good on that one is
you know next each week as we get closer
you know let's do this let's do it
you were the scales scales you know I
would love to do that cuz um I think
it's fun I think both both titles know
what their competition is you know and
um I think it's pretty interesting let's
be honest they're close releases you
know it's gonna be a fun battle man it
at the end of the day I like this even
for destiny because everybody's gonna
have to step they gave up to keep that
to keep your fan base to keep your play
account
oh you glad to step your game
No so there's a flood tides a good time
for the looter shooter genre I'm excited
you know I'm saying you got at them
going to vision as of this week let's
see next week last word how we feel when
we get more information
yeah and Destiny's gonna be sitting
there me like alright we launch gambit
that stuffs there a couple quests roll
out see what everybody does but guess
well we've been doing this for five
years you got some experience now they
feel like they through three years of
experience at the window with forsaken
no I mean they've had a lot of rough
learning curves in there but they have
had some learning curves to go through
already
now Dominion has been doing it for a
while too and that's where some of the
experience and division has some quicker
adaptation of changes yes we don't know
how fast anthems changes are gonna
happen how quick they can implement
updates like that sort of thing yeah I
say we gonna learn about that laughing
oh yeah
I mean division was division was a
bounce to almost too fast to make
changes that was an issue once because
like they steered a little more towards
streamers on say like division tech and
currencies and all of a sudden the
casuals like what the hell yeah like it
got a little too rough so there there
are those things to see once actually
that everything goes out how it goes
mm-hmm I agree yeah yep so that's who's
asking a new mode coming out yeah
there's a it's the evolution of gambit
its best way I know how to describe that
little phrase of whatever's coming with
the we got our bit too cuz don't don't
let Trials come back cuz it destiny try
to tow truck oh yeah when did you back
you wanted at the launch of a long I
want to joke around what it at the
Lord's launcher Joker's wild that was
the bet okay yeah I think he'll you'll
be taken take another people was likely
yeah so annual past Joker's wild weapons
a geared new gambit experience mm-hm
what the hell is that you got sir
Bonnie's you got Joker's wild weekly
crest you got try if you got a couple
exotic quests those are there but the
new gambit experience
what is that what is that coming at the
same time that's like straight-up early
March yeah yeah how about so yeah I'm
with you man I hope Division two doesn't
make the d2 FOMA be like oh we're gonna
make all these changes and we're gonna
forget about the stuff we brought in and
trials gambit sad to me I could actually
see that as being like you know a way to
mix up that mode so so yeah we are
coming up on about two hours guys been a
hell of a lot of fun though in chat as
well
and yes anthem is using the Frostbite
engine so given oh yeah the future is
bright and we have no idea which one's
going to shine the brightest yet there's
a lot of there's a lot of questions that
we need answers demos are gonna get us
some answers as news gets closer
destinies are gonna still be doing this
thing so stuff will continue guys but
yeah we can pretty much wrap it up there
don't have a couple minutes of a late
start but all in all it's been a hell of
a lot of fun this morning so everybody
who tuned in if you guys listen to this
later as well whether it's your your
channel or mine I am working on getting
the audios up I've got a place to put
them I just got to see how the feed goes
down we're kind of working on logo too
so I can actually have an icon when I
have the feeds that would make it over
here so those little pieces are working
to come together so you guys could get
your iTunes of you check this box is a
cargo for three hours you could do it
show was almost named Longpoint remember
yeah fill the thing but yeah if you want
to wrap your side and I will mine I
think we're pretty much probably gonna
wrap it for the morning raw concrete oh
man from the iron Lords podcast but
every Sunday is the Lord's Day Sunday
1:00 p.m. Eastern no guests this week
just the Lord's but trust me it is gonna
be fun
I'll give you a sneak peek we are gonna
have a hilarious Mortal Kombat
discussion that that is on the plate
we're gonna talk about that's gonna be a
hot topic a lot of stuff going on in the
industry you know all meant some fun
topics I'll just give you one one is
going to be Mortal Kombat in all aspects
of that reveal so we'll break that stuff
down we will
a little bit more also on um destiny you
know I'm just gonna be division and
anthem will touch a little bit more as
well
probably not as extensive as deep as uh
me and my man II but you know I try but
uh yeah man it's gonna be fun man
Sunday's 1:00 p.m. Eastern Iowa podcast
channel at Laura Cognito on the Twitter
and make sure make sure if you guys are
on discord you know please or join the
Lords of gaming discord I'll try to get
that out to you guys ASAP it should be
in the description on my channel so
check that out it's really fun we
actually have chaplains for everybody so
if you're a fan of destiny we got you
obviously you know I'm saying for all
you guys in here I'm seeing a couple
division fans seeing anthem fans please
we have dedicated chats for you guys so
you can just talk with your friends you
can fanboy out you can go the other guys
chat and say why they Lou the shooters
not good at it better than yours oh my
god you can have some fun with me but
it's really fun man I really enjoy it um
yeah I'll try to get you guys the the
link up while he watches girls but uh
yeah check us out Sunday man and I'll
make sure please subscribe to my man man
he's out here he's killing us the solo
content the bond test is really really
doing a tremendous job so if you have
not served to Eve on sisses channel it's
gonna be a problem what are you doing
with your life I mean come here exactly
if not live in the right life I mean I
just try and you know you guys have been
awesome and as these games are coming
I'm gonna try and cover to them to the
best of my ability
I don't do this full-time so I will do
my best but you guys have been
supportive me this far so I will keep my
keep it coming as much as I can and
dividing my world by free is going to be
rough we'll see how it goes
give me one second I just before I let
you do you're just want to give a guys
the the discord channel cuz I'm depth
you want to get you guys any man you got
your both chats are really really
tremendous I'm gonna dump that link in
there right now so he is for the Lords
of e bonta's
you guys go please hit that up when you
guys can
and talk some gaming have some fun with
the Lord's and obviously most of people
in ILP you guys will have it already so
I'm throwing it in there there you go
nice yeah for me you guys know where to
find me it's right here on Twitch if you
guys are watching it live if you catch
it YouTube later it's twitch.tv slash
Cervantes Twitter it's Eve on to YouTube
it's Eve on ttis or if you guys find me
follow so like comments all the good
things and just every little bit of
support helps guys whether it's a sub
into the channel like in a video twitch
prime subs whatever you guys do if you
can't support cool if you just want to
watch and hang out also cool
just you know you guys are awesome and
it's just the little comments people
saying hey I just finished my first
hundred K nightfall because of your
video
it's literally why I do all right there
and those are the awesome ones so thank
you guys for the support both of us are
growing and again I know he said send
the love my waist and its iron Lords
podcast as well please go out there at
least subscribe to that channel listen
to those podcasts put them in your ears
and listen to that good wonderful
conversation hilarious discussions they
have in great interviews I mean kognito
right there is the glue that holds that
thing together but he will definitely
get you some great content when those
guests get on there
he gets the deep questions and
definitely lets those guests run wild
which is awesome so great times all
around and I think that'll wrap it up so
that's all I got and we'll see you guys
streaming next week in another video all
it is just I will see you guys in the
next one absolutely enjoy your day and
enjoy your weekend peace see ya